hello everyone and welcome back to the
round 11 of the 2021 candidates
tournament
uh it's anishkiri versus ninglian and
the dink has not been having the
greatest tournament he only got one win
in the first half of the
uh candidates against fabiana carwana
and he's been pretty much stuck in
uh well uh last place or sharing last
place ever since
and here in round 11 he faces anishigiri
aguirre has the white pieces and
this is a quite uh quite a wild one it
finished very abruptly and it was uh
well a very
uh swift game uh so without further ado
let's check it out
and see uh why this was so so geary uh
with
the white pieces opened with e4 and we
have
e5 that knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 so
uh just a normal rule opus here we have
a6 morpheus defense and bishop to a4 and
i know what you're thinking how can a
a rue lopez end suddenly well
uh here we have knight to f6 biting we
have castles and the bishop to e7
and nothing out of the ordinary with
bishop captures on c6
d captures and now d3 strengthening the
center here
bishop to d6 black also helps out with
the defense of the e5 pawn and now
knight beat uh to d2 with bishop to e6
biting
and now there are uh some very notable
games where moves like b3
was played and also d4 is a no move but
here gear replaced knight to b3
and it is already as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game so let's
see how being deals with this he still
has to decide whether he wants the
castle king side or he wants to develop
the queen and then castle queen side
because white castle king side
so you know could be a bit of a more of
a
of a dynamic game if we have castles of
opposite sides
and this is exactly what the ding goes
for he plays queen to e7
and okay we have knight to the a5 by
geary uh
an excellent score for the knight and
you can't really kick it away i've
played b6 just knight captures on c6 and
the knight is
although it's on the edge of the board
uh it's still a pretty pretty good piece
in the future you can play something
like maybe queen e2 d4 sacrifice tonight
here maybe
captain a6 who knows what might happen
but okay adding
castles queen side nonetheless and queen
to e2 now
as planned we have bishop to g4 now
saying okay this knight isn't going
anywhere
and c3 now uh we have c5 uh
and now comes a3 preparing b4 and if you
look at the position arm now like we
said when there are castles on opposite
sides you want to you want to attack
that's generally how you win
uh again when there's castles on
opposite sides but it's
much easier for white to attack black's
queen side than it is for black to
attack white's king side
because here if you imagine we just push
b4 we're already threatening to open up
lines even if black pushes this or does
something
we can still push b5 and then open up
lines this way whereas
it takes takes black a few moves to get
all the way up to those um
fg and h pawn because they uh still have
not been moved
so here uh while you could start maybe
playing on the king side
link starts with c6 and this basically
just gives another target to white
uh but uh it uh it works so let's see
how
how the uh dean goes about this we have
b4
uh geary or now threatens to open up the
b file but now
bishop the c7 now of course you cannot
capture because
the knight hangs so uh he needs to go
back with the knight knight to b3
and now we have knight to d7
saying okay if you capture here it's not
a problem uh
while you will open up the b file for
example captures captures there's really
not all that much
happening here i mean uh this knight
still can't move yes you can use the
semi open b file for your rooks but at
any point i can just you know play some
like b6 and my position is perfectly
fine
uh so instead after knight to d7 we have
h3 pushing back the
light square bishop we have bishop to h5
and now
bishop to e3 with a triple attack on the
c5 pawn
and now ding says all right i did
everything i wanted to on the queen side
let's now start expanding on the king's
side and of course the
he does so with f5 uh he has a nice
target on
on f4 and maybe he's even considering f4
to get rid of this bishop here
uh so bishop captures on c5 uh this
pawn was sacrificed by ding and now
queen to f7 and now it seems like
giri's attack has been slowed down a
little bit uh ding gave up upon and now
he's ready to start his attack with
g5 and g4 so here rook 8 the b1
uh that's the the uh well that's the
file that's
most likely to open up so you do want to
have a rook on that file
and now g5 here uh it's uh it's a very
tricky idea because here white can
actually capture
uh it doesn't matter that the queen
hangs because the black queen also hangs
and if something like queen to g6
uh then it's uh well it's uh goodbye for
white because for example knight f3
you're going to play rook h to g8 and
after you defend checkmate somehow then
f4 comes and then
the the the entire position just
crumbles for example g4 we can just
capture and checkmate to the the white
king
so instead after g5 uh e captures an f5
by giri
and now comes g4 attacking that uh
that knight and then if the knight moves
then ideas like captures you open up the
attack
towards the white queen the problem is
here giri has
knight to g5 comes with an attack on
black's queen
queen captures on f5 and now h4 this is
how he closes up the file
and um well you have to figure out what
to play here if you play something like
h6 it doesn't really matter knight to e4
is a
perfectly good option and if you try
something like g3
doesn't really do anything you just you
just blunder a piece and you don't
really have an attack or anything
so instead after this h4 move uh dean
tried
b6 to get rid of uh uh geary's light
square bishop but here
uh gary said nope you're more than
welcome to have that bishop i'm going
with knight to e4 and this is where
things start to get really interesting
now white has control of the d6 square
and it's up to dink to decide whether he
wants to
maybe try and consolidate maybe play
knight f6 to gain more control of this
square
maybe he wants to start pushing with g3
a lot of interesting possibilities here
but he decides to accept the challenge
and he plays b
captures on c5 and okay let's see what
geary had in mind b
captures and c five now uh again with
control of the
d6 square threatening knight to d6 and
now knight to f6
now both the rook and the bishop control
this but it doesn't matter
uh knight the d6 check you have to
capture this otherwise you lose the
queen
there's a a nice fork here if you missed
that
uh captures captures in now uh dean just
grabs the pawn on d6 so rook captures on
v6
and now uh the move that we've discussed
uh from the beginning of the game
d4 it's important to open up the queen's
attack towards the a6 pawn
and uh well here you have a lot of
options a lot of options indeed
and none of them are particularly good
for example
one of the better ones seem to be queen
king to d8
and then you simply allow queen captures
on e5 that's also one of the problems
for example queen capture spawn captures
attacks both the knight and
the rook and after you move the rook for
example pawn captures on f6
and the game continues with the white
position being
considerably better but black maybe
maybe has uh
some options of uh well play playing
this out to a draw that all depends on
how how girly would play it uh but
instead after d4 we have c5 by dean
i think it wasn't all that great on the
clock i think he was below
four minutes could be even below two
minutes but i'm pretty sure he was below
four
and it's only moved 27 so 13 more moves
to reach time control
but now giri just grabs it knight
captures on c5 as the rook was now
defending the a6 pawn
and here we have rook to e8 but now his
position is completely lost so feel free
to pause the video
and win this game for a niche while i
give you a couple of seconds in the
most simple way possible
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
doing uh anything like knight captures
on a6 queen to be
b2 also a possibility but the quickest
way is queen to c4 this is what geary
played and it was
in this position on move 29 that dingler
and resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh point is
you are threatening some very nasty
checks uh discovered checks here
uh one option is let's say rook c6 but
it doesn't matter you're just going to
play d5 and now
uh you don't really have an option here
you have to move away from the defense
of the a6 pawn
and you are very very uh slowly but
surely getting checkmated queen a6 check
king d8 you're gonna deliver queen d6
check
king to c8 and now knight to a6
threatening checkmate
and after you move the rogue doesn't
really matter where you're just getting
rook to b8
checkmate so that's one of the options
and another one
also a nice one is not blocking with the
rook but rather moving the king but then
you just suffer severe material loss
knight b7
check king has to move you're going to
grab this rook
captures now you can capture here with
check all of the lines have been opened
rook captures and now rook to b7
completely cut off the
black king from from escaping then rook
to d1 is coming and there's not all that
much you can do here
if queen e4 let's say you offer a queen
trade queen c7 check king to e6 now rook
b6
check king to f5 and now we play queen
to g7
and there is no defense either queen
captures here is is the game over or
queen to g5 checkmate is game over
so only one of the lines but of course
thing knows that after queen to c4 there
is nothing more to be done here
and of course he resigned uh which
brings giri
incredibly close to the leader of the
tournament janipam nishi but we are
going to discuss the standings
after we show at least one more game
from around 11 of the candidates and
then we're gonna discuss the standings
who can do what who still has time to
catch up
and so on so that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank edmund freeman
vladolar raymond zhao
david kimura and lucas berlund for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day